it looks like the Stargate movie plan
might be dead but is there a possible
Silver Lining a Brad Wright Silver
Lining welcome to CRA your Sci-Fi TV and
Movie Channel doing a video I really
don't want to
do it was this channel that first
dropped the news that Amazon were
looking at a Stargate movie deadline
then reported it and several other
insiders after us but you heard it first
and exclusive here now sadly I have to
drop the news that it might actually be
dead that during the strikes Amazon
might have rethought its position and
come up with a new idea maybe let me
tell you though what is going on and why
do I know what I know so if you are a
regular site trucker you'll know that I
have sources that work working and
around the industry and thanks to those
sources I get to hear a lot about what's
going on and because my sources know
that this channel in particular and and
myself are massive Stargate fans when
there's an opportunity to get me some
information they tend to grab it in this
case there was a conversation between a
very senior MGM executive and um people
from um a wider audience of the industry
they're mostly agents and things like
this the discussion was about how the
recently announced redundancies over
Amazon and MGM might affect certain
projects that were already in the
pipeline so were there going to be
delays were there going to be any
shortages of Staff etc etc during that
meeting the conversation did come around
though to projects that haven't yet been
announced and whether there would be any
impact on those obviously these are
Talent agents and things they're
thinking about the next job so they
asked the question now this H up
executive then went on a bit of a rant
apparently and I've asked around a
little bit and apparently this is not
necessarily out of character for him he
is known to be a little bit fiery let's
say you want answers I want the truth
you can't handle the truth and it was
specifically about cinematic projects
like Robocop and Stargate was brought up
he actually
specifically stated the RoboCop was on
the back burner so was the Stargate
movie and that it was probably going to
get scrapped now he did not say the
RoboCop movie would be scrapped but he
did point to Stargate and suggest that
it was
dead
out out you so why is this happening and
what was then discussed in the meeting
well Cinema in the last 3 years or so
has changed dramatically comparisons can
be drawn to what happened in the 80s
when Cinema nearly died because of the
Advent of Blockbusters and the video
shop straight to video movies really did
became the invogue thing for a little
while and Cinemas really
struggled but we moved on and we did go
back to the cinema and in the last 15
years or so of the big Blockbuster
really had a Resurgence we had those
massive superhero movies and huge
franchises making a billion dollars or
more for every film that was released
the studios desperately clamored to get
that next big Blockbuster that next big
franchise that was going to make them
their
billions but then covid hit and
obviously that battered the cinemas but
when we returned we stopped going to the
theaters numbers are down
dramatically but more than that during
this period as well streaming services
really exploded partly again because of
covid we suddenly saw big movies being
released on streaming platforms first it
did seem that people kind of got used to
that and then basically figured why am I
spending all that money to go to the
cinema it'll be on a streaming service
in a couple of month mons anyway I'll
just wait but to go even further we
started to get used to the straight to
streaming movies being of much higher
quality cinematic quality Amazon have
been doing it for a little while Netflix
have been doing it for ages but Disney
started doing it Paramount started doing
it and all of a sudden our expectations
changed I honestly believe now that
audiences demand virtually Cinema
quality for for everything all of their
big TV shows look at the Lord of the
Rings a TV show that cost a lot of money
to make it was beautifully filmed and
people still complained about the
special effects occasionally look at the
new Star Trek series they cost nearly
$10 million an episode to make mainly
because the CGI the sets the quality of
the actors we demand it all to be to the
highest standard and there is maybe a
little bit of an attit that's creeped in
with the audience that because we expect
such high levels for TV Cinema isn't
special anymore so we stopped
going if you're enjoying the video don't
forget to like subscribe hit that thumbs
up leave a comment and all those things
but also go and check us out on
patreon.com sidre most of our videos do
premere there first this video actually
premiered near 10 hours before it did on
YouTube and a lot of our videos actually
premier year 24 hours before they do on
YouTube so go over check that
out it's taken the big studios a little
while to maybe realize this but Amazon
do seem to have realized it they did
have a plan that they were going to
invest a billion dollars a year into
Cinema I'm being told that that's no
longer the case we've seen that recently
with the Roadhouse movie starring Jake
Gillen Hall that's no longer going to be
going to the cinema but straight to
streaming in
instead and I think we're going to see
that a lot more A-list actors are now
appearing in direct to stream in movies
the business model makes sense for these
streaming providers because it keeps the
customer happy and keeps subscriptions
growing but also it limits their risk
they know how many subscribers they've
got they know their budget they can just
then spend that budget on movies each
year but if you send a movie to the
cinema and spent 300 million you kind of
need to see a return on that or it's
considered a massive flop and it makes
your company look bad and there are too
many movies recently that have made
their companies look bad Indiana Jones
so it does seem that studios are turning
their back on Cinema so this MGM source
is saying that Amazon are no longer
going to be moving forwards with a
cinematic Stargate movie how does fit
into some of the rumors we've again been
able to exclusively drop on the Sid Trek
Channel well one of the things we
actually said was at the start of 2023
that we were hearing that Mark Fergus
the guy that brought us um the expanse
the guy from penguin and a Parker the
guy that wrote Iron Man was in
negotiations to do something with
Stargate when the expanse ended Amazon
Executives went what are you fancy and
he went a fancy bit of Stargate please
and he did a bunch of development work
for this cinematic project back when
they weren't even sure what they were
doing with it now I heard that those
negotiations actually ended um late
December
2022 part of the reason was Mark Fergus
basically said look I'm I need to crack
on with God of War penguin and the
Parker's next big project for Amazon I
need to know though if we're doing
Stargate is it a movie is it a series
what sort of budget am I looking at um
where is it going to show is it going to
be on prime or freee or MGM Plus that's
all going to affect the tone of the
project I'm planning and Amazon couldn't
give him any answers now I hear that
then the decision to do the Cinematic
movie kicked in just after that in
January
February and the development work did
proceed we've even heard they were
talking to directors Etc but then it
seems at the end of the strikes around
August maybe
September there was a big meeting
between MGM and Amazon and MGM basically
made made the argument that No it should
be a streaming series and it should go
in MGM plus now I know that that meeting
happened because I have sources that
were
involved but we never found out what the
result was so we have negotiations that
we believe ended last Christmas and we
heard rumors of them starting again in
April but we're not sure we've heard
rumors of this meeting and we're not
sure of the result and
around the same time of that meeting
maybe just before I heard rumors
directly from the MGM and Amazon
marketing department for their
Distribution Company that they were
looking at plans for everything they
were planning to do in the next six
months or so everything that basically
the marketing department was planning to
release news Etc but they were told not
to bother looking at Stargate now at the
time we wondered is that a good thing is
that because they're got ahead oh we
might get announcement soon but we did
as well mention at the time that this
might actually be a bad thing it might
be because the project was on hold or
maybe even dead and now it looks like
dead but there might be a silver lining
I'm not dead yeah he says he's not dead
yes he is now this is partly speculation
and we're going to add two and two to
hopefully equal four here a little bit
but when asked this high up executive
did state that MGM plus would be getting
Stargate series but it probably wouldn't
be this year now that opens up an
interesting possibility we're still
going to be getting Stargate we're
actually going to get the series most
fans really want that's all good but it
also opens up another interesting
possibility it shows that Amazon can be
convinced to change their minds it shows
that MGM plus actually can convince
Amazon to change its mind and that the
executives like Mike right over mg plus
can still have an influence with people
like Jennifer S over Amazon and if that
is the case we know that there are big
players at MGM plus that are still very
supportive of Brad Wright that he has
his fans over there and that Mike wri is
one of them so if MGM plus does really
get its hands on a Stargate
series could that increase the
possibility of Brad Wright getting
involved or somebody else maybe Robert
Cooper or Jose MOSI or maybe a couple of
them it's an interesting possibility and
we can only cross our fingers the MGM
executive did though talk a lot in this
meeting about how frustrated MGM was
particularly with in the current climate
with Amazon they said they had lots of
projects on the Go including Stargate
they had plans for Stargate they had had
Brad Wright script and they had another
idea as well and they were developing
them strongly we could have been on our
second or third season of Stargate by
now if Amazon had just let MGM do it
that frustration apparently did bubble
over a little bit in this meeting so
that is the upside potentially there is
a very serious downside here though and
a massive
risk I was told a little over a year ago
now by somebody that does work in this
industy for a very long time and knows
the industry doesn't necessarily have
any inside knowledge about Stargate or
MGM but knows the industry and he
basically said look a franchise like
this we need it now the momentum is with
it we were TR it was trending on Twitter
quite regularly and things like that but
if it wasn't announced by the he said
late spring early summer of
2023 then he honestly expected this not
to happen for several years and when you
get to around the 20e mark of a series
leave in asens then it becomes very
difficult to do any sort of
continuation and at that point a hard
reboot is far more likely or at very
least some sort of project that is only
Loosely based on the original we would
not be getting any Legacy characters
back etc etc so it does feel like this
is a Now or Never situation let's hope
it's now
and let's hope it's the series we really
wanted in the first
place guys get into the comments going
and tell me what you think this has been
dragging on I've been able to tell you
everything that's going on and you know
at times it's been
frustrating seeing behind the curtain
has really shown us that these people
don't really seem to know what the hell
they're doing but I'd love to know what
you think now is dropping the movie if
that's what's happened really a good
idea and in that case do you think
that's more or less likely we're going
to be now getting the series we mostly
want it in the first place anyway can in
the comments tell me exactly what you
think if you are new to the channel
don't forget to like subscribe hit that
Bell notification it really helps us on
you'll never miss any of our new videos
also go to patreon.com citrek where most
of our new videos do Premiere first and
you get to see them without the adverts
finally go to citrek do.uk which is our
dedicated website and we do articles
based on a lot of our videos with a
little bit more in for you to digest go
check it out as always please stay safe
and I'll see you next
[Music]
time